I was a date xx right good evening
everybody
welcome to the Development Committee
20th of July 2017
first of all horribly emergency
evacuation announcement in the event of
a fire or other emergency please exit
the building in an orderly manner to the
assembly point which is located in the
market carpark there are two fire exits
located in the room clearly indicated by
the green fire exit signs please don't
delay the evacuation by collecting any
belongings and the premises must not be
re-entered until the fire service is
given the all-clear please remember it's
against the law to smoke on these
premises and also note that the meeting
will be audio recorded thank you
item one is apologies for absence there
are none there are no substitute members
non-members attending have cancer
Stanley
oh good Inc thank you minutes of the
meeting held on the 25th of May 2017 it
happy for me to sign those as a correct
and accurate record of that meeting
thank you
declarations of interest let's step toe
take shed a non-pecuniary as I remember
of Essex County Council with regards to
item six related gift items here's
councillor Williams
thank chairman Yellen pecuniary interest
item six member of Rochford parish
council ward councillor for that area
and I have a relative living in Roch way
okay thank you okay thank you members
just before we get on to the items
there's an addendum with some see one or
two significant changes to the the items
can you confirm that you're all you've
all got that that you've seen it you've
had chance to take it all in it wasn't
circulate it immediately at the time of
the minutes okay I think you're
perceiving that just for our visitors
the the format for the meeting is we'll
take each item the officers give a
presentation then any visiting speakers
that have pre-booked will talk then it's
our non-members then the members of the
committee who will discuss prior to
making a decision and this one small
change would like to make to the running
order and that's to swap bottom seven
and eight around but our first one is
item six youth opportunities center
Roche wait Rochford demolition and
redevelopment and for a first time
sorry for the first time we have mr.
although heavens to present to us thank
you
Thank You chair it's because of an
appointment that one of our visitors has
okay Thank You chair good evening
members member the Catholic I'll just
run through a few slides and introduce
the scheme I'm sure members have have
time to read the report and the report
is also published for the benefit of
members so we'll go through a few slides
and take from there right so what we
have is the development site itself
stand up here so this is the former
college sports field career this is a
southwest corner of the southeast corner
of application site so we're looking in
a northerly direction and rochway is
obviously this road here to just give
you an appreciation of the other site
context so go through a few slides to go
onto slide 2 so this is the existing
site plan so that is the expense of the
application site is aged in red on the
plan so this is the footprint of the
existing building this is the northwest
corner of the site with Roger being here
and you can see that obviously on the
north side of the site and to the west
there is residential development over
here to the east is designated Greenbelt
to the south of sports pitches which are
also designated open space which are
also green belts just to clarify as in
the report the site itself actually is
also designated Greenbelt
despite actually constituting built form
of present we're going to slide 3 so
this is the actual site
layout plan as it currently exists so it
indicates that there are there is
packing of all it's not marketing in
sort of any paints obviously there is
parking to the frontage of the site at
the moment which is understood to be
used in connection with the use of the
sports pitches to the south we have
disability Essex as well which is let's
have a look which is in here somewhere
sure whether it is now but yeah this
would be s60 down there isn't it on
there this one years it's for the PS six
there which is accessed via that carpark
air is the front at the moment
go onto slide 4 so just two and just a
brief those persons have got some got
the benefits of knowing the site
intimately so this is just a shot
looking at the site from rochway at the
northwest corner of the site you can see
this distinctive boundary wall with
railings which the development proposes
will be kept as part of the development
with the exception of a central access
point into the site so it's a
single-story building the large roof
voice I describe the building a brick
building quite imposing building we'll
move on next slide this is just a shot
looking at the site from the other
direction so this is the current access
so this is taken from the taken from the
north east corner the site from rochway
now the reason for showing you these is
basically just to give you the site
context in its entirety so this shot is
taken from a public footpath which is to
the east of a sites or from within the
Greenbelt currently have a line of trees
along the boundary of the site which
these trees it is proposed some of them
will be crowned in order to make way for
the development so the development will
be built quite close to that eastern
boundary with the Greenbelt we move on
so this is Purdy's way to just give you
perspective looking in a southerly
direction and the next shot will give
you another view points are we going
round in a circle so this is looking
north so what we have then is off the
off the plan here is rochway but as in
sort of coming out and spurring out into
Greenbelt we have built form here which
continues in that northerly direction so
although I think what these pictures
SIG's emphasizes although the site is on
the edge of the Greenbelt it's not a
continuous straight line so it does the
settlement does just out into areas of
the Greenbelt in that manner so if we
move on this is a site again looking
northeast so we're having a 360 degree
view from the site if you like just to
give it set in perspective to move on
again that's looking east towards the
mills is it's thumb bridge mills the
mill building is here quite an imposing
building so it is rural in character
when looking out from the site in an
easterly direction however it is
residential and built up in character
when one is looking in the other
direction so ok that's from Ridge Mills
and that's then we've gone a 360 degree
circle now back to the Purdy's building
such as assess it in its perspective
really just for benefit so there we are
and this is a shot just to provide an
ERV and all other site which is taken
from the southeastern corner of the
sports pitches looking at the rear
elevation then of the building with you
just move on
so I'll just set out the development for
you as per report in fact so slide 13
scheme layout phase 1 & 2 so the scheme
will take place in two phases phase 1
being this development of 14 open market
dwellings which will be 2 & 3 & 4
bedroom dwellings so for this central
spine rod which will provide access to
the sports field that's the intention so
and then phase 2 phase 2 will be this
development of 60 independent living
apartments served by 31 car parking
spaces at the rear and the idea is is to
have this sort of central courtyard area
with an outlook from the apartment
development into a safe central enclosed
environment in the middle but also
providing views out into the open
countryside in an easterly direction
we'll go on then to the street view so
just to give you a flavor so if one was
standing in rochway looking at the
development this would be the frontage
of the site so what we have here is
these two and a half story type
townhouses five of them consisting of a
mix of brick material with other minion
highly efficient windows pitched roof as
you can see there will be a balcony area
with a garage underneath so they look
like link ounces and then there is a
different type house on the corner just
to give us like some distinctiveness and
this is the central access point the
spine road leading in forsyth the site
in a southerly direction and you can see
the the three-story apartments actually
they're not actually any higher is
slightly lower you know in terms of the
height when compared to the three-story
townhouses
so that that's basically a street view
these flat apartments will be served at
all private Terrace at the front they
will be a hedge boundary to the front
separating them for
on rochway the existing wall will be
left intact and closed in that area
where the existing access is that brick
wall will be closed up so there will be
the effect will be there'll be an
enclosure between the public realm which
is that of rochway and the private realm
which is the terraced area that will
serve the apartments at ground floor
level and then you have a two further
two stories or fluttered apartments with
in Phase two if we move on so this is
basically just showing the site layout
again just to explain what we have we'll
come on to the type houses the type of
houses that are proposed but the garden
areas that will serve the property
they're all in excess of 100 square
meters therefore complying with the
national space standards on amenity
space to serve dwellings so these will
be the townhouses that you've just seen
on the plan then with further dwellings
sitting behind those served by private
garden space with an outlook on to the
street scene if you like and then
basically whilst phase 1 is in progress
the plan indicates how parking will be
safeguarded for use by those people who
wish to participate in sport on the
sports pitches so that clearly
identifies phase 1 and what will happen
on site during phase 1 which will be the
provision of this parking area and for
the duration of phase 1 move on
so again I think this is quite useful
just to show you and give you a flavor
of what actually that development would
be like if you are on site as it were so
these are the are the the frontage again
with rochway so you've got the garage
and the link and then the terrace above
so now that that is the the design and
basically just Shores again this gives
you a long section just indicating gives
you a better idea of what actually a
place would feel like when it's actually
built and established to move on again
so what we've got here we've got
different type houses this is the type a
house which is the two and a half story
townhouses so there's a mix of four
types and I'll move on to the next slide
which shows type B
[Music]
can you just bear with us please thank
you fight be house okay so you can see
just just a mix of materials really so I
think it's have any residential
development the the applicant have
identified in line with design practices
a mix of materials which gives a slight
interest and variety so what we have
here is it's not a two and a half story
dwelling the type B house which these
are the houses that will sit behind the
the type a houses which are the frontage
houses will move on again that's the
type C dwelling and I'll move on to the
last type go to the type D so that's the
type D dwelling will go on now to the
phase two elevations so this elevation
here is B so looking this is the the
elevation along the site frontage so
that's just giving you the effect so you
can appreciate I think the reason we're
showing you these is for you to
appreciate scale now the the photograph
of the slider the bottom actually shows
a section through the the actual
building if you like it's not a
multi-story cap I could may appear like
that but it just shows you the heights
of the actual accommodation it's a
litter it's a shot through the side of
the building to give you an idea of
height so we'll move on to the next
slide again this shot here I think is
the eastern aspect I think but it's a
long elevation so the elevations are
very similar really in terms of scale
that the important thing to note is the
scale of the windows and the height and
the massing and the design really so
there's a parapet roof effectively so in
terms of it won't be completely sort of
like a felt roof there is a parapet so
that's an important part of the design
as
Wow and this are any questions emerging
from this I don't mean to sir cover it
in great detail but I just want to show
you the scale and the extent of the of
the elevations or move on to next
elevation please again I think that's a
shot looking from the bottom of the site
through at the rear of the frontage
apartment so standing south at the back
of the site looking through at the rear
elevation of the frontage building with
rochway so we'll move on and again just
to give you a flavor that is a
perspective view of the application of
the phase two so that's the kind of feel
that it's proposed to be created by this
development so there will be a private
Terrace at the ground floor with a small
terrace with glass balustrade etc on the
first and second floor you know the
important element is you know solid to
void ratio this nice large windows in
terms of providing outlook etc so I
think that's that I'd like to just sort
of summarize I'm not see the intention
of a scene isn't is not to me to go
through the report but I just want to go
through key issues and I'm going to show
you a few more slides before handing
back to the chair so I think the the
important issues I have a principle of
acceptability of the scheme so these are
covered under the section 5 of the
report so I think these for the transyl
these are the key considerations for
discussion as as it is considered by
offices so the principle of
acceptability point five point seven of
the report in in summary indicated the
site is no specific allocation as it
could not be anticipated at the time of
the preparation of the development plan
that the site will become vacant point
five point eight of the report indicates
fundamentally that despite being within
the Greenbelt
the site itself is will
kated within an area which is have the
envelope I built form so in terms if you
could remember the photographs I showed
you in terms of the properties to the
west of the site ie disability Essex and
the properties at rochway that is that
sort of encapsulates that principle so
it is M block by built form 5.10 of
reports
consider the principle of safeguarding
the character and openness of the
Greenbelt which is which is a
fundamental objective of chapter 9 of a
national planning policy framework and
consider the question as to whether the
objective of planning policy in this
respect would be undermined by the
proposed developments those are the key
issues 5.12 of the report considered the
fundamental principle of whether the
proposed development is considered to be
an appropriate development in
appropriative element being that key
consideration within the national
planning policy framework which by
definition would be harmful for the
Greenbelt and which should only be sort
of approved and permitted in exceptional
circumstances the national plan a
Quality Framework indicates that when
considering planning applications local
planning authority should ensure that
substantial weight is given to any harm
to the Greenbelt very special
circumstances will not exist unless the
potential harms the Greenbelt by reason
it inappropriateness and any other ham
is clearly outweighed by other
considerations you will note from point
five point one three of the reports
which highlight exceptions which include
include limited in filling or partial or
complete redevelopment of previously
developed sites ie
brownfield land whether redundant or in
continuing use the National Planning
Policy Fink therefore indicates there
are there are exceptions which basically
justifies developments within the
greenbelts 5.15 of the report is the
summarize has to be considered within
the context of the built development it
physically forms part of I think that's
the main consideration within the report
and 5.16 of the report concludes that
the development is not an appropriate
development as defined by paragraph
87 of the National Planning policy
framework on the basis that it is
acceptable to develop on previously
developed land you will note from the
report quickly that there of the
material planning considerations we've
taken into account the provision of
specialist housing is in Section five
point one line of the report the need of
for specialist accommodation is covered
in five point two six of the report
affordable housing provision and tenure
the proposals proposed 41% affordable
housing provision the housing mix which
is section five point three nine phase
one is two three and four bedroom houses
and independent living of one and
two-bedroom house in phase two so the
cause with policy on the basis of a
housing mix the landscaping section
indicates that there's landscaping in
place to replace those trees being lost
on the eastern boundary of the site on a
one to one ratio which is considered
acceptable transport and high users
covered in Section five point five nine
it's a sustainable location and it's
concluded there was no impact upon
operational desperation of existing road
network ecology has been covered by the
survey with mitigation which would be
subject to the European protected
species licensing process the drainage
the site is in a flood zone one which is
which is low risk the drainage strategy
is considered acceptable where there'll
be no spillage of drainage of surface
water drainage on the road the folder
images onto gravity system the national
space standards being completed as
mentioned earlier the operational
impacts in terms of development of the
site and impact upon amenity can be
controlled by condition right the key
issue now I'd like to just refer back to
the slide before closing and I'd like to
consider the relationship of this site
to the other built form such slide not
point two not to six
just to consider the right so in terms
of aiding members and public to
understand how officers have come to the
conclusion about design and layout
acceptability we have to look at this
development in relation to the built
form around it so what we have is a mix
of dwelling types in the area there is
no strong design reference such as they
would be for example along 19 South
Street or somewhere like that we'll move
on so not to send that's the existing
built form on rochway and this is
leading then on to the design and layout
acceptability just looking from the back
of the site of this of these houses so I
just want to sort of conclude my
presentation by looking then at the key
one of the other key issues within the
report which is design and layout
acceptability you'll note members that
points five point four three two point
five point five one of the reports
highlights the key issues being
addressed and concluded in point five
point four a third report and basically
what the report includes is that the
development is considered acceptable
given that there is a lack of any strong
sense of architectural character in the
area development would not be out of
keeping or in Congress with a locality
such that it is considered that the
development of comply with policy BM one
which is a design policy point five
point four line of the report also
considers policy BM to which considers
the efficient use of a site in a manner
which is compatible with its use
intensity scale and character of the
surrounding area the scheme does does
this or the density of 74 dwellings per
hectare the scheme is considered to
accord with a policy CN 2 including the
Essex design guide and the nationally
prescribed space standards and just to
emphasize this point I'd like to show
you slide not and not to nine which is
your
North the three-story townhouses along
the frontage well this is sort of the
design reference for the streets there
are lower storey dwellings along this
street but if you consider what has just
been indicated with design and layout
and acceptability that is the type of
design form that you see along rochway
so one has to consider is that developer
reasons massing and scale sort of
totally out of character notice sync
with what's around it that it could be
deemed to be harmful and conclusion
based on what I've just read out is that
it isn't harmful I'd like to show you
slide not three zero again that's the
the corner of the street and put a large
imposing building almost a two and a
half story building so comparing that to
the development that's how officers have
come to the conclusion on the design and
then not point not 3-1 just again just
to sure there's a an eclectic mix of of
properties just to move on and to close
we've noted the public objections and
the impact upon residential amenity
that's been raised points have been
raised by Oxford parish council these
points are covered points of objection
by the public hall obviously covered in
points five point one to seven to five
point one three to so in summary there's
a perception of harm so we've looked at
the issues number to see the pro Fitness
of its development with intersecting and
the relationship of the proposed
development of existing built form so we
understand there are concerns however
given the distance that the the
properties are across the way now phase
one is setback 13 meters from the edge
of rochway granted phase two is both
much closer to watch way however the
output is all the street and it's
concluded that the the key issue really
is whether the the degree of overlooking
adaptor section of overlooking
is all the bearing and when one looks at
thee the calculation for what is
considered to be overbearing I will have
to conclude that the scheme isn't it
overbearing by by reason of visual
dominance overbearing overlooking the
packing issues the final issue that I
want to just mention the you will note
that in phase during phase one this is
the parking arrangement
we're aware that this is a historic use
of a sports field and also designated
open space for people walk their dogs
and walk with their families etc so one
of the key issues is when phase two is
developed at whatever time that would be
where would the parking currently
provided and current and to be provided
during phase one the issue revolves
around the the appropriate provision of
an alternative parking solution and that
we have received a response yesterday
from sports England and I'll just read
the summary of the response currently
it's an objection is made for the
planning application as a strategy
console T in its current form Sport
England supports the revised officer
recommendation to defer the decision on
the application so will our permanent
and deliverable parking solution to
support the use of the adjoining playing
field to be fully explored if the
application is approved against the
latest officer recommendation our
position would be an objection and the
application would need to be referred to
the Secretary of State to allow
consideration to be given to whether the
application should be called in for his
determination so just to conclude
therefore members you will note that an
addendum was prepared yesterday and in
line with the advice received from
Sports England yesterday which is
reflected in point four the addendum
under item six it is now my revised
recommendation further to the issuing of
the reports but the applications be
deferred in order to provide sporting
London to consider this matter further
and for the relevant parties to explore
solutions and on that note I'd like to
pass back to the Jen and thank you
Thank You members we have got an officer
recommendation for deferment however we
have got some people that would like to
speak on this item and I do think in the
in the way of helping goes ultimately to
make a proper decision I think it is
worth us pursuing with discussion
tonight and under determining whether we
want to defer or not rather than they
met having a motion for object for
approval or rejection so I'm proposing
that we we move forward on the basis of
the offer of recommendation for
determine that the purpose being to hear
out the arguments to allow us to make a
fuller and more comprehensive decision
at a later stage so our first speaker is
mr. Jerry Gibson from Rockford Parish
Council
five minutes and then we're let you know
when you've got a minute ago thank you
Thank You chair good evening ladies and
gentlemen Joe Gibson Waterford parish
council and the parish council had a
number of concerns about this particular
development and now that line knows
briefly the first one is we believe it's
the 60 assisted living places is
overdevelopment it will make the site
very crowded but also there is a excess
of supply over demand for assisted
living within Watford itself a second
major concern is as planning officer
referred to this issue of parking when I
was involved with junior football many
years ago you used to get maybe one mum
and dad and a very lovestruck girlfriend
coming to watch the games now it's a
family outing the whole family come and
grandparents and aunts and uncles come
and surprise surprise they all come by
car and the difficulty is that the
residence of roadway are concerned that
unless there's some sort of traffic
survey darkness of the amount of cars
that come to matches then there will be
parking spilling over onto the roadway
and a number of them have dropped curbs
and the people to a nap late for matches
they park anywhere the third concern is
public transport the report makes
reference to the fact the public
transport is close by now as you may
have gathered I've got limited mobility
and the nearest bus stop to South End is
10 minutes walk away and the nearest bus
stop from South in these 15 minutes walk
away
and involves crossing three very busy
roads the fourth concern is that someone
said it's all irrelevant because people
can use mobility scooters to get around
watch hood the difficulty with that
those of you who know watch hood is that
the pavements are very narrow in the
sense of Rochford and one often comes
across people driving their mobility
scooters in the road rather than on the
pavements because of the nature of the
pavements fifth there is the problem of
aircraft noise what with airport is
developing as we all know which song was
very pleased about
but planes are now taking off and
landing right over this particular site
landings not too bad taking off makes an
awful lot of noise my last point chair
is that this building the adult
Community College where I was privileged
to be chairman of Governors for ten
years as iconic status in launch hood
generations of watchword folk attended
to school when it was a school for your
four generations in some family cases
and what we would ask chair is that if
the committee decide to approve the
application that there be a caveat
placed on it that the developer has to
provide some sort of public amenity
replacement for the for the college we
are over blessed with public amenity in
Rockford and so therefore it would be a
great help to the town we know we have
the freight house we're not sure about
the future of that we've got the parish
rooms and we've got the Women's
Institute Hall but neither then that big
so we would want a replacement community
facility from the developer if that
could be arranged that's all chair thank
you for your attention ladies and
gentlemen
Thank You chair that is what would
counsels view on the situation and we
ask you to reject
to the application thank you thank you
thank you sis mr. Steven Butler is the
agent
five minutes I love having that hello
anyone minutes ago Thank You chairman
members and officers my name is Steven
Butler and I am from bidwells I am the
planning agent representing Essex
housing on this planning application
Essex housing is a new function hosted
by Essex County Council on behalf of all
Essex public sector partners Essex
Housing is tasked with delivering new
housing on its and its partners surplus
property assets across the county the
delivery of new housing on the former
adult community learning site on Roch
way would fulfill this purpose locally
within Rochford the scheme would deliver
60 units of independent living
accommodation alongside 14 family
dwellings comprising 74 residential
units in total independent living is a
new concept which is designed to provide
new housing care and support to
vulnerable older people it is Essex
housings intention to move as far away
as possible from the traditional model
of institutional care to care in the
community where people can live
independently and with dignity in their
own homes with the care and support they
require independent living still gives
the reassurance of 24-hour care on sites
it provides community facilities to help
residents stay connected to their
friends and neighbors the environment is
safe and supported and there is the
option for residents to continue living
with their partner if only one of them
has a care need within the independent
living accommodation there would be a
50/50 split of private and affordable
accommodation within the proposed
development as a whole this equates to
41% affordable housing provision which
significantly
seeds the policy requirements it is also
necessary to bear in mind that this
policy exceeding affordable housing
provision is proposed on a site where
vacant building credit would be
applicable the applicant could therefore
justifiably reduce the affordable
housing significantly but is choosing
not to because of the wider public
benefits the independent living
proposals would bring to Rochford this
previously developed site within walking
distance of Rochford Town Center is a
sustainable location for the proposed
developments working with offices we
have formulated a scheme design which we
believe is acceptable importantly it
would retain vehicle access to the
disability Essex trust links site to the
West as it is legally obliged to do
demolition of the existing unlisted
building on site enables the new
development to optimize the use of the
sites furthermore the Highways Authority
has no objection to the proposals
including the amount of parking proposed
for the independent living accommodation
and the private market units the scheme
would accord with Greenbelt policy
because it is previously developed lands
we acknowledge the functional
requirements of Hamburg Colts who use
the land to the rear of the application
site for sports pitches and who
currently use the hard landing at the
front of the application side as parking
this is why taking account of the
amended recommendation from your
officers put forward in the addendum we
have commenced discussions with Sport
England to explore potential ways of
accommodating the displaced car parking
we are working with your planning
officers and Sport England to deliver a
solution that is acceptable to all
parties in this respect I therefore
respectfully request that you note the
officers recommendation to enable Essex
housing to explore this solution fully
thank you thank you
councillor Stanley you know the first of
all visiting members indicated okay
first of all ways about the parking
situation is there adequate parking and
I know it's from the slide that they had
one car in the road which showed the
vehicle access
just how are the other cars going to get
past in that road when they're occupied
to two or three cars per unit on the
housing that's going to be built there
as for the parking for the play fields
or for football and what-have-you
we have a similar problem in Rory's
where we haven't got adequate parking
places for the cars approximately we're
told what proximately 300 cars were
going to be parked at this particular
venue it turned out to be two thousand
cars and how you're going to get two
thousand cars to those playing fields or
anywhere near those playing fields is
quite it's going to be quite difficult
so on the parking situation I find that
a bit difficult for that site where
we've got the housing and we say two and
a half houses they're really three-story
and obviously the land slopes away I
think to the left to adequate the same
level rooftop level they could I asked
in some cases they're going to be
flat-roofed properties even though
they've got a parapet found could I ask
if that's is that compliant with with
the design or for for the council to
pass and also are the is it donors that
are on the front or are they the windows
in in the Rufus Hills
thank you yeah that's the mr. hi it's
right Thank You chair the concerns I
have around parking is when I just like
confirmation around actual numbers here
we've got 14 commercial residential
dwellings in the first phase which are
not assisted living they're just full
market properties which would require
under the standard twenty four spaces
plus visitor spaces which can't what
number would be I think I'd make that 28
or 29 in total and then we've got and
then we're going to have a phase two can
you confirm how many spaces will be
available for the phase one properties
and how many are for the phase two and
then also a greater on the base of what
you've said about the deferral from the
officer on the basis that the it's very
unsatisfactory not having any idea how
Park is going to be dealt with for the
stalkers films at this point thank you
alright councillor step toe switch out
okay should be answered now because that
might be end of it now sorry Thank You
chair the first question alters was the
roof design of phase one so if we go to
[Music]
zero one six which is yeah that's the
street view so the question was from
comes to Stanley I believe walls were
the dormers on the front so so basically
that is the street view from rocks way
so these two and a half story dwellings
they will have their gable elevations
facing rochway
so there'll be windows in the main
elevations this is the garage and then
there's a veranda area with a bedroom
here coming onto the veranda so I also
not the point that you made in relation
to the land levels we have a picture of
land levels if you go down to figures
the main slide show again and there's
one label they're showing land levels
have a look I concur it may well be I
concur with transfers family is
basically if we go to the site plan then
again just answer that question briefly
if we go to the existing site plan zero
zero two slide zero zero two yes so just
answer that question raised on the north
western corner of the site basically if
one was standing here so this is where
phase one is to be located and the
frontage those six dwellings that you
saw along the frontage will be here
there is a differential in land level so
I can make out if one was standing in
the our area here there's a differential
of two point four meters from the level
of the yard area relative to the road
level at rochway so those properties
will be sitting down within the site if
you like so when you're on watch wait if
we go to slide Street view from not
raise it fourteen yeah so if one was
standing in Rock Shui rochway looking at
these properties relative to rochway
these would be sitting down within the
site relative to that
area of rocks way opposite them so that
heights of things about 9.10 about ten
meters in height they're quite high but
the effect of them will be less because
of the land level I think the third
question was the spaces that was raised
the parking spaces that are raised so
all plan number schema layout phase 1 &
2 which is 0 1 3 basically to answer
that question
phase 1 there'll be one parking area
within the garage and one parking area
on the drive so in terms of the parking
standards that would comply with the
parking standards for the 14 dwellings
and then there are 31 parking areas
within this area here for in connection
with ease of this phase development it
equates to not points:5 to not point 6
parking spaces per unit given the fact
that it's a AC to users in the use
classes order if one were to look at the
parking standards and one would not be
able to conclude that that is an
inefficient level of parking and so
that's that's the conclusion on class
chair thank you
gas sector
thanks chair and I'm quite happy with it
the move to defer the unit but a couple
of quite classic ation the presenter
from the for the developer mentioned
that the access to the accessibility
site disability site would be maintained
I'm unclear from the drawing there as to
where that will be I think that needs to
be a little bit more defined and
certainly the question with regards to
the with the development looking at the
parking requirements for the sports
field I'm not sure like her counselor
standing correct
was he suggesting we needed 2000 parking
spaces perhaps I misunderstood what he
meant by that because I found some
clarification you there counselor sure I
can sorry counselor mrs. Holly you don't
need to stand for me oh I came for
physical console and yeah over a few
questions little bit and the three
stories because when you say assisted
living do you mean like there's some
some W mean victim was just easy things
that what you mean what do you mean by
Jo just just a brief brief description
of assisted living
please
it's basically where and someone may
need a certain level of care not to the
degree that they would need nursing care
but the planning statement indicates on
average six hours per week care with us
just help with minor household tasks so
it's a it's somewhere in between sort of
being totally independent in terms of
non assisted and nursing on it's a fact
sort of okay yes thank you
okay just turn your microphone off
please so the three-story apartment
order and would say what they have
listings
it is assisted would they would they
automatically have list
yeah okay okay all right and then my
further question is um obviously cuz
it's three stories high
something is there any M thought if
there's going to be any fire exit I
think I got adequate if I can cut in
there what we're looking at here is the
principal of the development taking
place the the actual technical detail
regarding Building Regulations is
outside the decision we're making but it
will comply with the it would by law
need to apply with the appropriate fire
regulations final question is it and you
show me a job in a zone am i
phonetically the to to rooftop terrace
outdoor living is to rooftop cavities
for outdoor living and barbecues etc
have you have you got that on any real
diagram what can you point where they'd
be the the purpose of tonight's
presentation isn't to show you every
diagram and drawing that we've had that
would be shown on the roof plan that we
haven't actually bought with us to the
presentation because it wasn't felt that
was material to the consideration the
substantive issues in connection with
the application so I wouldn't be able to
show that tonight chair now but farmer
alright
and I just like to refer you to then um
section call which is over in rora by a
Spurs they built those flats with three
stories and there's a rooftop terrace
there but sanctuary condemned it through
health and safety beam so they weren't
allowed a rooftop terrace shortly so I
wonder what the difference is between
this one and that one was
okay thank you sure thank you Jeff Oh
what my question is is there any
provision for social housing in this
development yeah so from the on the
basis of a planning application its F
it's a 50/50 split 30 units are for
social housing from correct
that's what stated in the application
and some of the rooftop terrace in in
terms of the design guidance it's been
put four basics housing that is a matter
for building regulations just to address
the other question on the plans it does
show stairwells on the end elevation of
buildings for Kazu as the chair alluded
to it has to comply with all the
regulations on fire and safety etc it's
a high standard of design that respect
okay guess the hoc way Thank You
chairman I've got a number of questions
given the opportunity to ask this with
regard to the recommendation and the
spine road that the main feature that
runs through the design is it intended
that that is completed in its entirety
so that the sports clubs can have proper
access to the facilities of the football
pitches before prior to any major
development actually taking place yeah
the question is how many we know how
many football pitches are actually in
the area to the adjacent to the site and
is there any indication as to whether on
the actual designated site is is there
any facilities going to be on that site
too for the sports clubs
any changing facilities being made
available as part of the part of the
development is there any indication as
to any of the parking spaces being
allocated for for use for the sports
clubs to use as part on this on the
actual site there was mention I think at
the beginning when there was talk about
the Lange designation as of Greenville
and it was mentioned that the within the
existing building as it is that the
central area is actually classified as
Greenbelt within within the building is
that correct and lastly the design of
the the three story sort of flats looks
very 1960s from the drawings is there
any is there any attention to with
regard to that was that an intention of
the design or that just by accident
thank you
I think what we'll do is well get the
other members to speak and then we'll
come and sum up with the bag at bag of
the the questions later
it's councillor Wilson next place Thank
You mr. chairman and just a correction
actually the developers agent said that
Essex County Council highways were in
favor of this game but at 4.10 of the
report we've actually received no
response which is unusual I'm a big fan
of Essex County Council highways who
always have something to say but not on
this occasion and that leads me to
question 5.63 how did we arrive at the
statement that we're content with the
Transport highways an accessibility
perspective what evidence have we got
from active thank you
councillor Williams Thank You chairman I
do have concerns regarding strippers
I'll note that there would be a scooter
storage facility will the foot passing
rot should be improved to make the use
of an expected increase in the use of
these mobility aids there are to be only
31 parking spaces for 60 units this is
0.5 2 spaces per unit is that enough are
those spaces to be over the science so
that they size to make car access easier
for residents with disabilities or are
they going to be of normal size I feel
that a three storey building is totally
inappropriate with balconies overlooking
mostly bungalows at the bottom end of
Roche way this in my view is
overdevelopment do we need this quality
quantity of assisted living
accommodation would Rotch would not be
better served with a mix of affordable
starter homes family homes and fewer
assisted living units I don't there are
to be no affordable family homes on this
development this needs to be addressed
another concern I have is the parking I
know this area well and on match days
the traffic even with the car park
that's here at the moment spills over
into the roads and it causes can
absolute congestion the site was a
community asset which was lost without
consultation
what would replace it however I would
support that this slightly developed but
feel unable to support this application
as to the excessive quantity of assisted
living units and the insufficient
affordable family homes I would rather
see a rejection to this application
rather than a deferral thank you that's
the mountain Thank You chairman I don't
really want to repeat points of already
made by the members but there are a few
things few questions that I do have
again regarding point four four point
ten Essex County Council highways no
response received as members sort of
advisory at what what's the position on
that if we were to raise objections
based on knowledge of the area if we
haven't received a response from Essex
the aiways that's quite unusual normally
they do have something to say on the
matter
and I'm it interested to know how we
respond to they're not responding it was
mentioned about airport noise especially
on takeoff and I understand from
previous speaker that was related to one
of the reasons why the previous facility
with the college the school closed down
I haven't heard any response into that
that the noise pollution issue and
looking at what's on the screen in the
moment I've got to just say I think it
looks really ugly and you know beauties
in there either beholder etc but looks
more like a 1960s office development
than a domestic it is awful sorry yeah
in my opinion it's aesthetically
unattractive and I wondered that if it
was to be refused or even if it was to
be deferred that possibly we could
encourage the developers to go back to
the drawing board and come up with
something more aesthetic for our
residents and our our district thank you
thank you and a description America it
has the black I felt the design was
something of an elephant in the room and
I'm glad you mentioned it we we had
mentioned that earlier on that there was
something of an amount of heritage to
the existing building and then the
officers were talking about the design
guides and notes that could be taken
from the the residential housing that
was around I feel that perhaps the
design does need to reflect back to some
of the design notes that can be found in
the existing building as opposed to the
existing residential I'd consider that
the designs that are in front of us to
be exceptionally urban and we're not in
an exceptionally urban area we're in a
an area that about Greenfield and on the
screen at the moment the very bottom
flank I believe is what you would see
from the Greenfield looking in and I
don't feel that is is appropriate
council back if you if you'd like to
speak now and then I'll come back those
with long term a little good points we
made I don't think it's quite as awful
as nineteen sixties I don't think we'll
ever get to that media development ever
again
having said that I think you've summed
up seven pretty well but it does seem
very urban and it is in between belt and
the edge of of Greenland and I think
that's a mark against it and I can
understand why members of considering
voting of moving refusal by don't think
we've had a motion yet and we need to
have definite reasons I am intrigued by
County highways not responding I'm not
always being a fan of my colleague here
is however we've got we've had a holding
objection from from supporting they all
sees do holding objects they've actually
seem to reply straight out with a
refusal or a straight-out objection
I'm just I'm only wondering whether it's
worth waiting for
clarification from Sport England so that
we can add it into the visitors refusal
of over the other hand we have got a
holding objection is an objection and
maybe if members were minded to refuse
then that could still be added is a
reason for doing so thank you members in
the discussion we've had there's a good
number of points that have been raised
where further information is required
and in particular we've got a holding
decision as counsel about just explained
from sport board England and an officer
recommendation for deferment I feel that
if I were to list out all the particular
areas that I've noted as we've been
speaking and this item were to then be
deferred it could come back to us with a
further clearer picture on what we're
talking about about I could go through
what I picked up where I believe we need
further information to help us make us a
more informed decision so in the first
instance we have the parking for you for
when the sports field is being used
that's clear it clearly a lack of
clarity over that and how that will be
handled the amount of parking on site we
do have some definitive numbers but we
don't have we have questions about the
size of the spaces given some of the
issues that some of the residents might
have there is shown an access road to
the disability site but the method of
the transition and any contact between
that site and exactly how that would
work is not clear enough for us we have
a question about the outdoor living
space and the clarity about the the use
there and how that might impact on the
the the other residents we need some
clarity with regard to the phasing of
the road when that would go in how the
different phases of the site would would
be created there are questions about
community contribution towards
facilities and sports facilities that we
don't have the answer to at the moment
we have Essex highways where members
have specifically requested a little bit
more clarity I must admit though if
Essex highways don't put a contribution
forward then it normally means there
that content we have questions about
mobility scooters and the parking of
those given that we've got the issues
around mobility and living restrictions
or some of the resident
then that that's a clear and fair
question
the issue of aircrafts is that they're
noise the flight path suite we want a
little bit more clarity in that although
it's not considered a significant issue
and then the design issue the
exceptional urban presentation of the
design again on the screen in front of
you you see the full flank presentation
of the houses which would be going on on
to Roche way so members are I will put
it to you that we need more clarity on
all of those issues officers have
specifically requested time to get
clarity from Sport England and how they
how they want to produce
I think the item needs more work and
because we've had the opportunity to
discuss all these things raised on these
issues I believe that if this was to
come back to us we wouldn't be in a
better position to make a decision for
approval or rejection as the case may be
so from the chair I will move that this
item is deferred thank you well good I
just want to make sure though just
before we go for a vote are there any
new issues regarding this that you wish
to raise so that we can have the clarity
on a future decision can't continue Paul
thank you can and could I just get some
clarity on the visitor spaces for the 14
houses and according to item five point
six one there's two visitor spaces for
the 14 houses we add that to the list of
clarity that we we need thank you
that's the Hogg way and you know don't
think this is one of my issues but I
think it was a councillor Williams
brought it up in relation to the mix of
affordable housing the fact that they
seem to be a lack of affordable family
dwellings just wondered if that could be
adding to the list as well Thank You
councillor Merrick Thank You chairman no
doubt I'll be corrected if I'm incorrect
but there seems to be an inconsistency
paragraph force point four one five says
for the lead local flood or thority we
do not have get to granting obtaining
permission subject to the following
conditions and it then sets out the
various conditions and in paragraph four
point one nine it says if you are minded
to approve the application contrary to
this advice
it's a CMC's being consistent with the
previous paragraph we request that you
contact us to allow further discussion
and or representations from us and I'm
wondering whether there have been a
contact and any further discussions or
representations so an anomaly they're
trying to just answer that one chairman
forgive me and that we've had that from
time to time where I think it's a victim
of cut and paste from previous replies
and they do as a reply and then leave
the tile of something from another
application so I take it the the point
with the inconsistency but that's
probably an error on their part they're
clearly raising my objection all right I
think if we're deferring we'll we'll
come back so they said under Kane South
those members in favor of deferring this
item please indicate as again that item
is deferred thank you that's some work
to do on that one all right our next
item is item eight coming back to seven
in a short while this is 8 Harrow close
hauled well and outbuilding to use as a
playhouse
he's doing this one
I'll protect absence so we did
microphone with him up yeah
just try get once more that's it
this application relates to this house
on the corner of her own clothes it's on
the eastern side of the hawkmen
residential area and has a backing onto
the Metropolitan Greenbelt as you can
see here the application is related to
is reported committee as the applicant
is related to a member of the RTC staff
the building which has already been
largely completed lies very close to the
boundary of 65 Park Gardens which has a
garden shed close to the shared boundary
you see this is a body itself the
outbuilding would be about 15 metres
from the rid preserved lis of this
neighbor the play house when completed
would be four meters high with the floor
a of 7.7 square meters a maximum length
of five point two meters and the width
of 2.8 meters the building would contain
a mezzanine floor above the ground floor
area of about 1.5 square meters for
storage purposes and would be
constructed in rendered block work with
timber cladding and a pitched felt roof
the building would have five sides to it
and fits the corner of garden set back
about Norfleet two meters from the site
boundary as you can see from this there
would be Windows at ground and first
floor level facing back towards the
application property but no windows in
any of the other elevations facing
towards a site boundaries
the building is within proximity of
Valeri of Woodlands to get to a cleat
protection order although the closest
trees are a minimum of about 5 metres
from the actual building itself given
that the building is largely constructed
and is without substantial foundations
the council's woodlands officer does not
recommend any conditions or have any
concerns about Davonte itself officers
consider that the proximity of this art
building close to the bounding of
neighboring properties would materially
impact on visual amenities of the
occupiers with a building appearing
visually intrusive and dominant within
the rear guard environment in the
conclusion of the committee report the
officer stated that an acceptable form
of development could be achieved if the
mezzanine floor is removed and the roof
height lowered I would also state that
permitted vermin rights would allow for
an outbuilding located more than 2
metres from the site boundary to be a
height of 4 metres with a dual pitch
roof or 3 meters in the case of other
reform so if this building was located
elsewhere on the site and had a slightly
reduced height they probably would be
committed development thank you thank
you speak on this one mr. Peter bliss on
behalf of the applicant
okay five minutes I'll let you know when
you've got me yeah thanks very much good
evening chair ladies and gentlemen I'll
be brief
this proposal as as you can see 3/4
built I speak on behalf of my son Steven
bliss is a resident and owner of eight
our close all right now with regards to
the Playhouse mr. bliss has apologized
previously for his mistake he thought he
was building it under permitted
development in you that you could build
up to for me to side with a pitched roof
but he hadn't picked up but he had to be
less than 2 metres from the boundary and
that was the problem that he's had and
so he carried on with the building and
he advised all of his neighbor's of what
he was doing during it and prior to
construction he discussed many times
with his neighbors the product of the
project all were encouraging including
the lady at number 65 Park Gardens mr.
bliss hopes to build a playhouse that
complements the natural wooded
surrounding of the site with sympathetic
finish and materials he didn't want to
buy a plastic Playhouse he wanted to buy
something that blended in and he's tried
to do it with a imaginative design the
costs of the construction and the time
taken have been prohibitive in
comparison with purpose-built plan
although he thought he could build it
without a world within PD mr. booth LM a
son has contracted constructing the roof
to reduce the height at the fence with
number 65 so had the actual fence at the
back end of this building is it has a
hip it's a hip indeed roof
so although it's a four meter pitched
roof from the front at the actual
joining with the fence of the people of
the lady who is objecting to it the high
is actually two point three with a roof
sloping away at 45 degrees to join the
full for me to reach which is away from
the fence
considering this mr. bliss was most
surprised to hear the objection from
number sixty five number seven a I
believe has objected on behalf of sixty
five as the boundary with number seven a
is why away from this proposal view from
the conservatory at number sixty five
the Playhouse is behind a garden shed
and a large ash tree on the site of
sixty five to the left side of a large
garden the Playhouse as has been said
it's approximately fifty feet from the
conservatory mr. bliss is happy to
provide growing evergreen foliage to the
roof facing sixty five or whatever is
deemed adequate to shield the structure
and to remove the mezzanine floor in
conclusion mr. bliss does not want to
upset his neighbor and hopes that
agreement can be reached and that some
flexibility will be viewed with this
proposal and that it may be passed thank
you very much
countess pepto just indicated so thank
you chef
I must admit my first reaction on seeing
it I thought it was perhaps of a better
design building and the previous
application and would have fitted far
better in the semi rural setting the
right way if this was to be passed I
would like to see a condition limiting
the use of this particular building so
it doesn't become some sort of granny
annex or similar for this substantial
were building there
Thank You members the recommendation is
for refusal on this one we've had it
indicated to us though that at a later
stage something very similar could be
built but not in this location that but
this one doesn't fall within permitted
development rights we've had a
presentation from the the officers so
members the recommendation for refusal
is on the page but can have those
members sorry can I just add to that a
little bit but if there is moved to
another position in the site but again
it's not used or the conditions put on
that it can't be used for any form of
granny annex for similar don't think we
can do that if it's permitted
development rights you know we can do it
so members those that those members in
favor of the refusal please indicate
okay thank you that's unanimous item is
refused back to item seven now
2:09 Ferry Road home bridge demolished
existing dwelling dwelling and construct
part 2 Story part 3 story building -
comprised of ten two bedroom and two
three bedroom flats there's been a site
visit to this one members I think will
be informed anyway but the the plans
have been amended slightly since since
that visit and there's clear information
about that those changes in the addendum
but we'll have our report first please
Planning Commission is sought to
demolish a dwelling and director
building to provide 12 flats ten two
bedroom flats and two three bedroom
flats site relates to this building here
it's located at the northern end of
Larry Road on the western side opposite
the turnaround from the buses and the
public car park the area is
characterized by modest dwellings set in
deep plots which would generally
consisted building line the site backs
onto the Kendall Park Nature Reserve and
some members may be aware that there is
actually a budget set in the woodlands
just to the rear there
the site is located between River breeze
court a previously developed site which
is now apartments this was admitted
about ten years ago to the north of the
site is a smaller detached dwelling with
them pitch new front doors like that
site areas is awkward to two hectares
and as a frontage up to 30 row to twenty
nine point six meters and a depth of 75
point five meters the principle for the
redeveloped of this site has been well
established over the past 20 years
in 2007 the council committed event of
14 in flats in 2008 devoted of 17 flats
was permitted on the site but neither of
these were actually built out members
may recall from the November 2016
planning committee an application of
14,000 refused due to its bulk and
massing
they're with me ma'am
these are the plans for the refusal of
2016 is quite a substantial building
that was refused basically a particular
three story form it's very wide it
doesn't seem to fit in very well with
other the buildings either side Council
are informed that in an earlier appeal
decision for 2005 application inspector
agree that a redeveloped on the site
with fat would be appropriate for this
location given its sustainable
credentials and it's varied form of
surrounding development the inspector
stated that whilst a three-story
building would not be appropriate if
three storey elements incorporating
accommodation within the roof board
would be acceptable this is an elevation
plan of the proposed building list
substantially different than what was
before as you just noticed the building
would set back from high rate and
broadly in line with the existing
pattern of development either side and
further down Ferry Road the design would
incorporate a variety of forms including
gable projections dormers and a stepped
roof heights in order to blend in with
diverse either side the heights of the
building itself vary between six point
six and nine meters and that
correspondence the higher of part of the
flats next door and the lower height of
the detached way to the north there will
be a mix of different materials
including brickwork render and tiles to
converse some of the materials in the
surrounding development the staggered
articulation different forms and
materials bring a degree of interest and
variety to the design this considered
that the designers scale would not be
over dominant or in Congress within the
streets in
since the members site visit has been an
amendment to the site layout and the
applicant submitted revised site plan
with changes to the areas of hard and
soft landscaping the revised site plan
makes a following changes an increase in
the number of parking spaces from 20
spaces to 24 spaces with 20 spaces
provided to the front of the site and 4
spaces to the rear all parking spaces
need to preferred a size of 5.5 by 2.9
meters with the spacious to the rear for
the four parking spaces would have grass
creat surfaces the cycle parking and the
bin store will be relocated from the
front to the rear of the building around
here the door to your reduction in the
size of the private garden area is to
the grand theft round floor flats a b c
and d and there have been increased in
the rear communal area from 403 to 555
square meters this site exceeds the
requirement for shared space for flatted
fellows which is 300 square meters for a
12 flooded government so basically you
got more than twice the density area for
the flats and what would be required the
occupy of 293 Ferry Road have concerns
about the use of the rear gardens of
such sizable parking areas and this
revised planners reduce the level
provision to the rear officers consider
that proposal is a significant
improvement on previously refused scheme
and the reputation is therefore for
approval thank you we've got two
speakers on this one councillor Ali
Smith hombres very council
[Music]
you know anybody
very short Thank You mr. chairman the
parish council have considered the
application and although we have not
ejected to in principle we are concerned
that the applicant has stated that the
residents can park in the Paul's Lane
car park as the application has
insufficient spacing the amount of flats
claimed we would like to highlight to
this committee that Paul's Lane car park
is managed by the Parish Council and it
is no overall parking order which gives
the Parish Council the power to move or
have moved any vehicle which breaching
this order our own maintenance staff
monitor the car park and we have
previously moved a car and at times have
closed the comp opportunity to event on
another matter
the site thanks on to Kendall Park
Nature Reserve which is home to a very
large beta colony magical and the colony
is just the other side of the fence of
the site and there are a number of
entrances and exits and suspect that
their tunnels are also under the rear
under Gardens we know the current owner
and spoken to Essex barrage the trust
due to the Badgers going into their
garden we are concerned that if this
application is passed that heavy
vehicles and machinery could disturb the
colony set we have to abide by strict
guidelines if we do any caucus in work
near to the sets in the reserve that's
all we have to say thank you very much
avnish also I'm stunnin who's the agent
good evening chairman members thank you
for your time and coming to the site
considering this application I'm sure
you're all aware that there's been
extensive planning history at this site
which is outlined in section 3 of The
Office report this includes four
previous planning approvals for the
demolition of the existing dwelling and
the replacement with the development of
flap it's highlighted that all these
submissions granted were actually for a
more intensified form of development
than now proposed which is only seeking
12 slats the principle of this form of
development has therefore already been
established the more recent application
of mentioned by the officer was refused
based on bulk scale and it was
considered to be cramped form of
development the applicants really taken
on board the concerns raised by members
previously and the officer and has
proactively worked with the council to
prepare a scheme which would receive a
favorable recommendation and pleased to
say that this is now in achieved this
proactive approach included having
pre-application meeting to the council
offices and also Essex County Council
design officer Peter Dawson who supports
the proposal to create a design which is
considered to comply with relevant
policies and provide a positive
contribution to the area as outlined in
the officer's report excuse me the
design respects the building line of the
adjacent residential development so on
the one side it's staggered at the
highest point with the adjacent flap and
then reduce down and to reflect the one
and a half story chalet on the opposite
side a staggered design also adds visual
interest provides articulation and would
be in keeping with the context of street
scene at the land naturally sloped
downwards in addition the width of the
building has been reduced and we further
away from this number to nine three
following concerns about the impact of
the occupy arm is swelling the overall
bogs been reduced this together with the
increased separation distance and the
significantly lower Ridge height ensures
that no other dominance would occur the
planning officer agrees with this when
assessing the proposed it against
relevant policy parking as we know has
always been an issue at this development
originally we submitted 20 parking
spaces which given a sustainability of
the area
was considered both by ourselves and the
officer to be efficient however
following the meeting I understand that
members wanted to still see some
additional parking space so you'll have
seen the site plan tonight amended so
that now each unit would have two
parking spaces each meeting the current
standards the majority of the spaces
again are also at the front of the site
to protect the amenities of number two
nine three with only four now at the
rear I trust this now I become the
issues relating to the parking no
objection doesn't raise from any
professional third-party consulting the
applicant to provided sufficient reports
and supporting documents to satisfy the
Parish Council the Highway Authority
natural England and the environmental
department and indeed the planning
officer who's now recommending approval
planning policy stresses the importance
of making an efficient and effective use
of land in sustainable locations the
application before you achieve this and
provides a high quality modern design
which makes a positive contribution to
the character appearance of the area it
would provide sustainably constructed
flats to meet the needs of current and
future generations thus contributing to
the shortage of housing in the district
I just wanted to quickly touch on the
points you raised and obviously the
parking in this application was never
seeking to utilize the car park across
the road the whole intention was to make
sure that we provided in this location
where obviously you can walk to things
and with bus services at least now two
spaces per unit which is considered
sufficient and in terms of the Badger
obviously secondary report was carried
out we're aware of where the Badger sets
located and the applicants are fully
agreeable to the terms and the
mitigation and in terms of not using
machinery to dig down within that 30
metre zone from the Badger set on this
basis I ask members to therefore agree
with the councillors recommendation and
grant Planning Commission subjective
conditions thank you very much our
visiting members of council mr. hoi ad
Thank You chairman I will be favorite
I'll just point out there's just cup a
cup of problems I had with the
presentation by the officer there I
understand there were four reasons for
refusal at the meeting for the previous
application to have recommended and I
think two already later at the meeting
itself one of which was on
the parking standard with regard to the
parking the parking now is 424 spaces
which agrees to wear standard for the
actual flats it's still 4 by 3 visitor
spaces however I think that applicant
has worked very hard to actually get 24
in there in the end under and given that
the property to the south the flats to
the south of this property only have the
had no visitor spaces themselves they
have 8 spaces for for for two-bedroom
flats that I think it's probably
acceptable now I can see from the report
that the the and from the plans that we
be shown that yet the original scheme
for the parking space to be nearer the
fence line and nearer the Badger sets is
now actually increase the space between
the two and I think that's beneficial as
well and I'd just like to thank the
applicant for making such good effort I
think the the building and the design is
far superior to the one originally put
thank you
yes Stanley Thank You chairman having
looked at the site and we went to the
site beating arm it became apparent that
obviously the Badger said whatever you
when we discussed that that would be
cordoned off so that that would no be
interruptions to the Badger set so we're
pleased about that
also the parking it really worked hard
on getting this done and I'm pleased to
see that there are two two parking
spaces per unit I would like if we could
put some sort of recommendation as to
next door has got a footpath in front of
it and I wonder if the developer we've
got to continue with that footpath to
make it more accessible for visitors to
the property as they can get get out of
the car and get onto the footpath rather
than onto the driveway of the property
which would be a good idea also if there
are visitors I'm sure that they will use
the carpark that's that's available to
them as visitors
whether whatever times they come I don't
know what time it closes but I'm sure
they'll remove their cars before the car
park closes in any case on that on that
episode I think it's a well thought out
plan and I'm pleased to see the
amendments to it thank you very much
thank you that's the Wilson thank you
mr. chairman and I remember when this
came up before the committee before it
was a whole combination of reasons why
this shouldn't be approved and I'm
pleased to say that the car parking has
been improved the fact that it's not
reliant on the Porsche Lane car park as
counsel Smith said the only thing is for
and consistency one of the points that
I've raised was that so the report said
that there was good transport links and
that hasn't actually changed so it
doesn't it doesn't mean that I'm against
it all I would say is if you want to
come to Holdridge after 11 o'clock at
night on the bus you can't do it if you
want to get out the village it's
difficult so just for consistency the
the bus situation hasn't changed it's
the same frequency thank you our members
we've got a recommendation for refusal
so I beg your pardon
included way that a recommendation for
approval we've got the various recommend
conditions stated on pages 7 10 11 12
and 13 those map comes mr. time can we
insist that I put the foot footpath in
no we've got the plan that's in front of
us that we're determining be okay you
know obviously the applicants are here
and they've heard what's been said no
that's fine so so those members in favor
of the approval please indicate thank
you that's unanimous
it's approve
and our last one tonight is item 9 which
is the old pumping station fanbridge
Road south umbrage thank you thank you
chairman if we can stick out rock on the
large scale there's a reason for that
chairman the the site is just about here
here somewhere we'll zoom you know it's
better for members to see but the point
being while we're out this far is to be
able to show members the sporadic nature
of the area because that's why we
recommend differently to why you might
normally expect you will see Blenheim
farm up here self fanbridge hall here
the churches some areas and a couple of
cottages there now to help members you
can zoom in on that image please Rob
members will see that the site's about
two hundred and ninety meters or so from
ashen road junction families red and
it's an awkward triangular shaped odd
piece of land that has I think legacy
back to the Water Company on the site
there's a brick built small structure I
think about I think six meters five by
four or so in size it's a very small
structure with the hip roof the point
being is hardly anything there there's a
footpath you see along that edge to the
it connects from the bend in the road
out to the other side but there's also
treed margins or hedgerows along this
side but it's grasped just a lone
solitary brick pump shed just a very
small building if we could just zoom out
a taps in please Rob the site area is
point four of a hectare and that's
relevant to later on because your
standards to deal with stables which
this application is about normally
require just this amount for one stable
and that's pertinent to the point that
we come on so if we can see the layout
of the site now please Rob members will
see that this application is unusual
because it more or less covers the
particularly the front part of the site
we've built form you'll see hard
surfacing the access the site is very an
hour about six meters wide here widening
to fifty odd at the back but you'll see
the applicant proposes to put in a
roadway a turning area build seven
stables use the brick
that we have on the site as a tack room
and food store and build a little toilet
for staff and sort of like a restroom on
the back there's one of those rotary
horse walkers and we see the elevations
in a touch plus a storage building with
a sort of road scalpings area so you've
got built form you've got a different
built form there you've got the
surfacing and then a small turnout area
at the back now the nature of these stay
was unlike those that you normally get
this is put forward as a sort of a
rehabilitation area for horses race
horses so they wouldn't be looking for
the normally extensive grazing that you
would expect with your policy they would
be resting they need some limited
turnout but they don't want the
extensive acreage that we normally see
now the problem we have if we can go
just through the the elevations quickly
Rob just give members a view of it
they're mostly about four or five meters
high but here's the stable building you
typically see that it's a good
traditional design if we flip to the
other elevations please you'll see that
it's got a brick plinth that ground
floor nice nice combination with the
weather boarding finish if you go on to
Elevation there's a button Rob one two
five if we would be on two yeah they
drop down at the top hopefully yeah see
at the top that's it traditional stable
building you've approved many times in
the greenbelt brick prints to the lower
Park weather-boarding to the size and
metal sheeting to the to the top if we
jump to the next one please Rob this is
the storage building open on one side
and clad in the others a gray sheeting
to the roof and green cladding to the
sides again what you've approved perhaps
many times if we can then have a look at
the next elevation you see this is the
horse walker it's a rotary you put I
think six horses potentially and they
walk around and then you turn around the
other way and walk around the other side
so they don't build muscles up too much
on one side it's an exercise machine
it's a good substitute for the lack of
grazing but that's not our concern in
this application if we can jump back to
the layout please Rob this site is
located in the Greenbelt but also the
coastal protection belt when we looked
at the
the aerial view over the site before we
saw the vast tract of hedged fields
small pockets of pasture there was in my
view not much else in the landscape it's
a fairly empty landscape now this kind
of activity here stable ink is
permissible in the green belt the green
bow allows it to be used for
recreational purposes which would be but
there's a caveat to that policy it says
that it must preserve openness okay now
usually what happens is we have a
planning application for an area like
this perhaps with another six hectares
of land so for the forsaking a small
part of the site the grazing that's
always required necessitates the bulk of
the site left open if you think of the
football pitch applications we have we
get perhaps a pavilion or particularly
containers but that might be serving
several pitches for the pitches that the
containers facilitate keep the remainder
of the size of the site open this
application is not like that this is
different this requires a more intense
development on a very small site which
doesn't then satisfy the test of
maintaining openness because the bulk of
the site although it's a very small site
is dominated by all the built form and
that makes it different to all the
applications you've you've approved in
the past of no trouble this site is also
previously developed land because of the
legacy from the water company and the
pump house and the caveat is a same the
comparison must be made to the size of
the existing building now you saw in the
in the aerial view that the brick house
is a very small simple building if you
then look at the size of the stables on
here plus the outbuilding the horse
walker all added built for why in excess
of that if members familiar with the
bull wood hall application they remember
we was comparing the size of the prison
buildings to the housing development and
Skylon that it was a comparison between
built forms that's what you have to do
with the previously verb land here it's
a quite simple test in officers view we
have a brick building with a simple roof
and then a very much larger extensions
proposed this is why officers are
recommending the way we are it's not
probably what you might typically expect
but hopefully members can gauge from
from what I said this is why we
recommend refusal now on the addendum
members will see that since preparing
the the reports are though on this one
the environment the Environment Agency
do not object their colleagues at the
lead flow local flood authority Essex
County Council have considered the flood
risk assessment because this is in a
zone free area which is the area more
susceptible to flooding the applicants
is amid in an assessment now that
assessment is weak in the lead flood
Authority's view on some of the
calculations that we've heard it earlier
this evening another matter a holding
objection has been put in and before the
lead flood authority could sign it off
as it were and say that it's acceptable
they would require those extra
calculations the position is with this
chairman is because it's in the green
belt and the coastal protection belt as
you'll see in the report whether the
application was able to achieve the
flood resilience or not which you
probably technically possible it doesn't
it doesn't undo the green belt harm the
officers are concerned about so the
recommendation in this case chairman is
a refusal for the reason set out on the
report before you but also the second
reason you'll see at the end of the
addendum relating to the flood issue
until one speaker on this mr. Keith Worf
who's planning agent
[Music]
okay right good evening chairman members
thank you for them sometimes this
proposal is for a small private
stable-yard
and the intention is for horses that are
owned by the applicant the original
office of recommendation was purely on
Greenbelt issues but I know tonight it
belatedly and the issue of drainage has
been added as a reason for refusal as
your officers rightly say green belt
policy is to be commended and its main
purpose is to prevent urban sprawl but
by definition green belt should be open
I would go on to say later on that
horsey
type things always need product land to
some degree because of grazing so they
will always be in the countryside they
wouldn't be in the built-up area where
one couldn't afford that sort of land
and in your planning officers report in
Clause 10 his states that this type of
use is appropriate in the green building
that's been reiterated by any officer
however implausible evany states they'll
still be significant development
compared to existing well there is a
pump house on site at the moment which
is relatively small but the whole
development in my view you may have a
different view but what in my view is
quite small we have tried to keep the
existing pump house and we've treated it
elevation ly slightly different to the
new build so that there is some
historical context people realize what
was there for originally the site is
brownfield and the government strongly
recommend that brownfield sites be used
where it's all possible we are trying to
do that with this particular site if we
go on if we couldn't have a question and
development in the Greenbelt look there
would be very few around London of
course
a large metropolitan Greenbelt if I can
go on to the flood risk assessment the
landing question is very flat but unlike
an commercial industrial or residential
development it doesn't really matter if
flooding occurs in a stable in fact
stables have quite often wet on the
inside when a horse please
so float flood flooding in my view
should not be a big issue and lastly
when we talk about horses they are very
much more in there's a lot more time
required for a horse than for many other
types of use and it's not just as the
person handling the horse there's an
indirect spin-off to farriers feedstuffs
vets tank so it actually is very good
for the rural economy as well so
although there's a recommendation for
refusal on greenbelt grounds I would
suggest the question isn't is strongly
supported by government in the green
belt and if drainage is an issue well
there is a case I think early on was
would suggest that it could be deferred
if if you want more information on
drainage but from my point of view
having done literally hundreds of
stables in the in the UK getting damp
inside a stable is not a risk that it
would be in a commercial industrial or
residential property thank you very much
for your time thank you
this isince been referred to us by
accounts the guiding so would you like
to speak for us Thank You chair although
this application is not within the hull
quest wall which is where I represent I
was contacted by the applicant and asked
if I knew why there was this suggested
refusal there seemed to be some
confusion at the time with the green
belt and
Brown field area so that is why I and
took it upon myself to take a further
look at the area and it is as already
noted a previous development on the site
and when I looked at the the Greenbelt
area it isn't it's two miles away from
the water's edge and which was a lot
further than I thought it was from the
report and I noted there's many more
housing around the water's edge so I
felt that that argument was not stacking
up in my view and so I've there was also
a time limit when this was brought to my
attention with a matter of a couple of
hours before the deadline so I I brought
it to the attention for members to have
a look at before it was just totally
refused out of hand thank you thank you
for your time Chancellor Stanley Thank
You chairman I believe the pump house
was put on there some time ago and it
was always deemed as Greenbelt in that
in that region there are several
concerns that I'd like to bring to your
attention is that stable in that many
Hobbes's will actually need transport to
and from the site as well as the feed
that they'll need and the amount of
water that they have to wash a whole
stair with is just unbelievable and take
two or three hours just to clean their
legs once they get in the stables and
once they get air the stables so I know
friends of mine that have got horses and
does take those up thankfully get away
from the heads on pure flooding you get
away from that old plating issue I've
just on planning the issue alone
there'll be a is quite flat land and it
will hold an awful lot of
so there's no high lane there at all
anywhere the on this stable issue that
many horses will need an awful lot of
feed are on site and there's not enough
room for that many it doesn't look like
many room for that many cars to to park
there with with stable lads and vets and
lorries coming and going sort of things
so I don't think this is large enough
for that thank you have no objection to
the design and layout of the scheme this
is a good scheme get the vehicles in off
the road there's a turning facility
there's ramps to unload it's good
storage and things like that the concern
is here is the amount of footprint on
such a small plot which hits that
definition to greenbelt we spoke of
earlier about it not maintaining
openness if this had been the same site
with several hectares of land way off
the plan you don't think you'd be you'd
be discussing it
this is an intense concentration on a
small plot to help the applicant with
the flood risk it's not about the horses
being damaged or risk through flooding
the ground sloping the way it is with
the the village on high ground the
Environment Agency say if it comes back
on this scale into the site into the
low-lying area there would be a risk of
flooding or surface water catchment
given all the hard services tipping into
the network causing flooding downstream
so it's a calculation imagine if all the
hard surfaces and buildings are like an
umbrella catching the rainwater putting
it into the system the issue is about
that it's not about the threat to the
horses or the other facility it's a
technical issue to do with capacity
which is why I think the lead flood
authority think they can fix it thank
you Jim thank you on that basis members
that when you're speaking if you could
attempt to focus what you say on on to
those two issues councillor stepped out
Thank You Chet I'm just picking up sort
of on that theme obviously this is
one available word is a intense care
unit for horses now it's always going to
be had to be staffed they're working
what facilities ie toilet facilities and
things are in place for those workers I
haven't seen anything as of yet I'm
pretty certain that it's unlikely to be
in two main drainage so where will the
effluent from that side of things be
dealt with having worked with a lot of
horses over many years yes I am aware of
the amount of shall we call it effluent
that horses can produce over a given
period of time how is that going to be
deal dealt with running into the water
course and in particular there are the
stables near me where when we go
planning permission for them we didn't
tighten up on the way the disposal of
the waste the the mark and the stuff
that comes out of stables and currently
I've got a set of stables where the
actual pile of muck next to it is
actually bigger than the stables so I
would like to see some sort of control
put in place if it is past that make
sure that that is taken away from the
site on a very regular basis okay at the
mountain thanks chairman and yeah I'm
completely in agreement with what the
officers have the offset said in terms
of the intensity on on a small area of
land that if it was larger than it could
be moved for approval but I'm completely
in support of refusal on this
application that we have in front of us
I do have a question based on a personal
interest I suppose in animal welfare as
much as anything that when we have an
application of this nature dewy is it
possible to get reports from animal
welfare RSPCA for example in terms of
their viewpoint on whether that would be
an appropriate development for animals
to live in
with flood risk and everything
considered that we've heard tonight
okay okay that's Newport just like some
up again hey Jeff and I've got to
disagree with the officer about animal
welfare in this case because we I don't
think we could put a condition on the
stables only being able to house X
racehorses for rehabilitation and the
amount of graze in there I don't feel
it's sufficient and it wouldn't meet
British horse Society standards so our
support refusal Kathir brag quite
pleased this is called in he's given us
a chance to look at policies of a
coastal protection belt but I support
them better than when they sent the
refusal it's quite clear it's contrary
to gb1
env2 thank you that's our way just there
just for clarity um I believe the
officer mentioned that the the area's
flood zone free so if this had been a
residential application it's highly
likely wouldn't have got off the
starting blocks just because it's
housing that equines I think we also
need to consider their welfare and and
it would seem that there's as a council
Newport is pointed out there's no
conditional guarantee that we can put on
as to what type of equine you know
horses are our house here and it could
be used for other purposes down the line
and they would be insufficient grazing
thank you okay that's the Wilson mr.
Chae and we had a similar refusal last
year I believe for in whole bridge round
and and the animal welfare does come in
British Horse Society standards and the
number of hectares a current member
office of might have how much it is per
halls and but that does form part of our
policy documentation and Welfare
in the countryside the question I've got
is how big is the turnout area and from
the British whole society standards
managing that Turner area is actually
key because you've got to you've got to
clean it up obviously it through the
year and and and maintain it so that is
a question that I've got Thank You
chairman taking that point last I don't
have a figure for you for the area of
the turnout but I do know that the area
the site as a whole is point four of a
hectare I mentioned that in the opening
so the whole site that you see would be
the grazing area for one horse one box
now the grazing isn't for feed it's as
much for exercise in actual fact you can
over graze a horse you can feed it too
much grass occurs laminitis etc and
becomes eeling can't stand up and all
those sort of things it's as much for
recreation which is why we sometimes
lower the standard where they're near
the Broadway network so where they can
relieve the pasture from from trampling
and duration by working on unmade rows
or the bridle way Network etc now this
area you'll see as a proportion of 0.4
is what roughly a quarter maybe maybe a
third so if I've suggested a third of
0.4 of a hectare and the standard for
one horse boxes point for this is about
a third equivalent to one one horse box
on the points of welfare that was raised
these boxes are to the size that
advocated by the British for society
normally about three metres by three
metres
it can vary in sound a horse if you've
got big sort of seventeen handcart horse
or something like that noticing need to
be stable if you've got Shetlands and
smaller horses then you need it
proportionately that these would suit
just about I think the standard requires
a British horse society for the horses
have been talked about the members asked
about welfare we I understand the
sentiment but from a planning point of
view we're dealing with the relationship
with buildings the impacts in the
landscape the welfare issues is dealt
with via the RSPCA and other other
bodies and the owners if they got
racehorses and things like this they're
likely to be in other investments as
much as pets you know I don't think
you're going to be looking at a welfare
issue from the point of view of the
development itself as I said this is a
good scheme it's just that it's too much
on the sighting in Greenbelt terms if
this had been several hectares and I
don't think we'd be having those
conversations that the amount of grazing
because of the nature of the work here
they don't need a lot of turnout as to
become injured again this is a rehab
where they would build up to then go
away to wherever they're stable
permanently and there's a point raised I
think about whether anybody's resident
on the site there isn't there's a small
sort of staff room if you call it that
with a toilet in there and so a
kitchenette that's not unusual on yards
where fairies and people come and they
leave dockets for bills and things like
this there is I believe it's not on this
plan but I think in my view of the
application there was some kind of
sewage facility for the limited toilet
facilities that are on the site the
member is right that we can if members
are minded to grant permission you can
have a condition where you put on a mock
away regime as it were so that the
applicant would be by condition required
to agree details for the transport where
the waste and then that could be
enforced against because it was a
condition it was found to not be an
exercise I think that's covered the
questions generally this is a question
from councillor black explanation mr.
strengthen I understand what you're
saying that the because of the there's
no surrounding hectares of grazing land
this is unacceptable
in terms of Greenbelt policy because
either it's a built-up area there it's
also in the coastal protection zone belt
and as one does how much extra weight
that places on the on the situation
chairman up probably been light on that
but you'll see from the report that it
effectively doubles up the idea of the
coastal landscaper though I'd probably
suggest a little bit more difficult in
this in this location let me go to here
a photograph drop the the land inclines
from this point if we can zoom out a bit
this area here is these high grounds and
the river itself you can guard a little
bit more so we can see the river please
Rob well
but Dad don't let it our site is about
here and the sort of the relief of the
land run through here and drops down so
you can't see the coast for this point
but the point being that development in
this area should be largely restricted
so that it keeps its of undeveloped
nature and enjoyment of the river as a
leisure resource so the we're not an
issue with the way that the belt has
been drawn the belt has been drawn way
back up here somewhere so it captures
all these areas in there
this site is within the coastal
protection belt it has the impacts that
are set out in the report which is
similar to green belt with them the main
issue here is that the the test that the
government requires if you are to allow
leisure uses or uses in the green belt
that's ok providing they preserve
openness and why we like stables
normally is that you get for the cost of
a small development in the corner of a
field somewhere because of the grazing
requirements etc by definition the rest
of the site has to be kept open the
reverse of that would be on this this
issue here it's not unacceptable in
principle it's the way it works on this
particular limited site I think mrs.
Franks has indicated that we're clearly
looking at planning principles but
members have made points about animal
welfare and perhaps contributions to
those discussions should they come up in
the future because the declare will for
members to to have some information in
that area and as a council in other
meetings we've clearly demonstrated our
commitment towards our animal welfare
but what we're talking about here is a
particular application we've had a
discussion about it there's a
recommendation for refusal with an
additional recommendation within the
addendum so we'll now go to the vote
those members in favor of the refusal
please indicate
okay as against that item is refused
right twenty five to ten and pretty much
[Music]
you